dans le cadre des journées européennes
du patrimoine qui a pour thème cette
année là venir l'icône hotech historique
de l'océan indien dans sa nouvelle
application smartphone une jonction
entre un patrimoine iconographique passé
et de nouvelles technologies qui
permettent de démocratiser l'accès à
l'histoire
alors on avait à lancer en 2011 le site
de l'icône attaque historique de l'océan
indien qui met en ligne des images
patrimoniale elle vibre de droit et nous
pensons que il fallait évoluer avec
l'engouement des internautes pour les
nouvelles technologies de l'information
de la communication et se lancer tout
simplement sur une application
smartphone donc retrouver le contenu
n'est qu'au notait avec une approche un
petit peu plus ludique parfois des
contenus ce sont plus de trente mille
images diffusées en ligne relatives à
l'histoire et au patrimoine culturel des
pays de l'océan indien avec lesquels la
réunion partagent une mémoire historique
et culturel va retrouver une galerie
d'image où on peut télécharger des
images librement puisqu'elles sont
libres de droit justement ensuite on
peut tout à tout simplement effectuer
des recherches sur la faune la flore
l'histoire de sang indien la géographie
dans le moteur de recherche simplifiée
on peut ensuite jouer découvrir quelques
connaissances basiques sur les îles de
l'océan indien
voir les actualités de l'icône au tec et
accèder gagne également contenus
pédagogiques aux expositions virtuelles
de nombreuses institutions culturelles
du conseil départemental contribuer à
cette banque numérique d'image on peut
pratiquement toutes les retrouver le
musée léon dierx le musée historique de
villèle les archives départementales le
muséum d'histoire naturelle et la
bibliothèque départementale
on a aussi des partenaires français et
étrangers sur cette petite application
une nouvelle application qui favorise
l'accès à l'information et qui offre à
tous des outils de connaissance d'études
et de création on attend bien sûr un
retour on s'aperçoit déjà que même au
sein de notre équipe là les jeunes sont
beaucoup plus réceptifs à ce type
d'entrée en matière d' approche du
patrimoine c'est un premier jalon vers
d'autres projets à numérique nous allons
mettre en place dans l'avenir